Evolution is the fundamental idea in all of
life science.
So if we raise a generation of science students
who don’t understand the main idea in biology
they’re going to be incompletely educated
students and this is going to be trouble for
the United States because the United States
keeps in the game economically by innovating
– having new ideas, new products, new ways
of doing things.
That’s what the United States produces and
brings to the world.
And if we raise a significant fraction of
our students who don’t understand science
we’re not going to have the engineers and
scientists to continue this tradition.
So for me it’s troubling objectively or
subjectively as one can be and as a citizen
of the U.S.
I believe, I think here on Big Think that
the problem is the same thing that allows
us to recognize patterns to imagine shapes
and things and routes and ways to get things
done before we actually start doing those
things that that ability also enables us to
understand that despite our best efforts we’re
all going to die.
And I think that makes all of us a little
nutty.
We all find it a little troubling.
And so because it seems incredible that all
this stuff that we store in our brain, all
the memories we have, all the mental images
that we are able to keep, all the algebra
that we learn, that all that goes away when
we die is really hard for all of us to accept.
And along with this is that we are not nature’s
last word.
We are not the final answer that nature came
up with.
That we are not what some entity created as
his or her very best work.
We’re just one more step on the evolutionary
timeline.
And for many people that’s so troubling
they can’t accept it at all.
For me, of course, it’s empowering and amazing
and it makes me want to live every moment
of every day in the best way possible.
But for a lot of people it’s literally unimaginable.
Our journey begins when I was in New York.
I’m living in New York nowadays but a year
and a half ago I came here on an airplane
and I had to be someplace for a television
interview at – I had to get up around 5:00
a.m.
Eastern time which was 2:00 a.m.
Pacific time.
And by the time I got to Big Think I was worn
out.
I was a little worn out.
And you guys asked me a fabulous question
about creationism.
I’m not sure why you chose to ask that question
and I spoke from the heart how troubling I
find it for the United States science educational
system, for our science students in the U.S.
to be excluded or not be enlightened and not
be enabled by the fundamental idea in all
of biology which is descent by natural selection,
evolution.
So you guys posted that and people went a
little crazy on the electric Internet, the
computer machine that the kids use.
And I just remind everybody when people take
the time to write and they take the time to
hate me that much, these are not people you’re
not going to reason with.
These are not people that you’re going to
sit down and have a conversation with and
a discussion and achieve a new conclusion.
We each have pretty much made up our minds
and so you can’t worry about that stuff
too much.
My concern is not for the grownups who take
the time to write these inflammatory things
and react to your fabulous website and so
on.
My concern is for the people who are still
in school, the people who are the future of
the U.S., the future of the U.S. economy.
And larger the future of the world’s economy.
I mean the United States is so influential.
It’s the third most populous nation in the
world and it’s the nation that sent people
to the moon.
I mean it’s still a big influence.
You can make very strong arguments for South
Korea, Japan – huge economies doing amazing
– Brazil doing amazing things.
But still the United States is the leader
in this stuff and so when we exclude a generation
of science students we’re headed for trouble.
I guess what I would just remind everybody
who is troubled, each of us who might be upset
by the inflammatory comments below the Big
Think videos, those people are not really
in the mainstream and I will state categorically
that if they really believe the earth is 6,000
years old they’re really wrong about that.
And that’s not an extraordinary statement.
But I can’t tell – I’m not sure if the
guys, the people at Answers in Genesis really
believe that the earth is 6,000 years old.
I’ll say they certainly seem to.
When you’re with them they certainly seem
to be true believers.
But they all use mobile phones, they all use
Facebook and Twitter and so on.
They take advantage of all of our technology
developed through the process of science.
They’re all happy to have had smallpox vaccinations
if they’re of a certain age.
Or they’re all happy to have not died of
smallpox, I’ll put it that way.
They’re all happy to eat food grown on farms
that is in general extraordinarily healthy
in general compared to other parts of the
world.
It’s not laden with bacteria and other harmful
pathogens that might be associated with food
stock.
Once in a while we have big trouble here but
the United State food system is a lot better
than most places.
And they take advantage of all of that.
But apparently they don’t seem to appreciate
the science that led to it all.
And what I find so troubling with the Answers
in Genesis people is they have a very diligent
or complete indoctrination program for young
people.
They have quizzes and workbooks and classroom
curricula designed to indoctrinate young people
in the extraordinary and obviously wrong idea
that the earth is somehow 6,000 years old
and there was a flood 4,000 years ago and
somehow land plants survived and salt water
and seawater mixed but there’s still freshwater
fish and so on.
All these bits of evidence in nature that
point out how obviously wrong it is, they
press on and they work very hard to indoctrinate
young people.